hey what's up guys my name is ciano
welcome back to my c plus plus series
so today we're going to be talking all
about iterators this is going to serve
as more of an
introductory video to iterators a lot of
people have been asking me what are
iterators should i be using
iterators have they been somewhat
replaced in the language
this especially comes up a lot in
universities who are still maybe
not using the latest class plus standard
in fact a lot of people message me and
say help me
my university is using c plus 03 which
is a shame because it's 20 20 but we're
not gonna get into the educational
system
in this video the point is what are
iterators
and do i really need to know how to use
them so iterators are
essentially a way for you to iterate
over a collection of elements
now the thing is an iterator is really
up to the implementation in terms of how
it's used meaning that
i could write a class called apple and
then add an
iterator to it that might not make sense
to you but i could use it in some kind
of special way
it's kind of like operator overloading
you can make the
plus plus operator do anything but for
the most case if we look at the standard
cpus library
we can see that iterators are usually
used for iterating over data structures
so whether that be a simple array that
you want to traverse or get through
every element in that array maybe you
have a vector
you want to go backwards through every
element maybe you have something a
little bit more complicated like a set
or a map or even a tree data structure i
want to traverse that
how do i do that well you need to use an
iterator it's really easy to overlook
iterators when you're just dealing with
a simple data structure like a vector
because we can simply use the index
operator using the square brackets we
can
simply stick a value into there and
retrieve
that element at that given index but
this doesn't always work for other data
structures
such as sets which don't really contain
all of our elements in order so anyway
long story short because i honestly
think this does not need to be
complicated
at all iterators are used to iterate
over a collection of elements and
iterating over them
is really simple as we'll see in a
minute but first you know what isn't
stuck in 2003 in terms of education
skillshare
for those of you who do not know what
skillshare is skillshare is an online
learning platform a community of people
who come together
to learn a new skill on the internet
whatever it is that you're trying to
learn whether that be illustration
photography
marketing business productivity
literally almost anything skillshare has
thousands of amazing classes for you to
choose from
and i love the fact that they're all
really concise and simple and to the
point
even if you don't need to learn a new
skill i mean i didn't think that i
wanted to learn about illustration
but to be honest it's been helping me
relax so much which i feel is really
needed these days
something like productivity it it's not
something that you
necessarily always set out to learn but
if you if you come across a class that
teaches you to be more productive
why not spend a few minutes going
through that and you can do that with
skillshare
because of those concise classes coming
in at just under 10
a month for an annual subscription it is
an amazing offer
but an even better offer is the fact
that skillshare is offering the first
1000 people who click the link in the
description below and sign up
two free months of skillshare premium
that's two whole months to check out the
wide variety of courses that they have
on that platform
and decide for yourself if you want to
stay and learn more or not
huge thank you as always to skillshare
for sponsoring this video
let's dive in and take a look at what
iterators are all about
so as mentioned earlier iterators are
used to iterate over a collection of
data now you can really interpret this
however you like it's possible to write
custom iterators
do a whole range of things but usually
when we think of an iterator we think of
having a collection of values such as
this vector here and we want to traverse
the entire collection part of the
collection maybe we want to go backwards
through the collection we essentially
have the desire to get through
at least some of the values inside this
collection so how do we do that well
let's look at some simple examples we
have a vector here
we have five values how do i print them
all out to the console
there are a number of ways we could of
course do that the most common way which
you'll probably think of
is a for loop that simply iterates
through values
dot size like this so that we go through
all of the five values that we have here
and then we simply use the index
operator here with the i
variable to just retrieve the data at a
particular
index inside our array here so if i
print this out into the console like
this and i'll add in a little sc
in get over here we should see one two
three four five being printed out to the
console as you can see that's what we
get
so we've essentially iterated through
this entire collection and this is a
pretty common way of doing that now
let's also look at
another way that we might do this
because we don't really need this i
variable is there a cleaner way that we
can write this and of course there's
something called a range based for loop
since it's c
plus 11. so what we can actually do is
write the data type here which is
end a name for the current element that
we're iterating over
and then finally the actual collection
which in this case is values so in other
words we're going through all the values
here
and then we now have this integer value
to play with that's our current values i
equivalent so we can just simply print
that out to the console
like this and well you can see that that
results in some very very clean code
this is usually my preferred way of
iterating through collections if i don't
need that i
variable and there you can see we have
the same result as before
so how does this even work i mean it
looks like seemingly magic code and it
seems to work for this vector class so
what exactly
makes it work with the vector classes
the vector class contains something
specific
that makes this range based for loop
work and how does that work
so the answer is yes it has something
called an iterator now we're not really
going to get into this
too much there's a lot of different
types of iterators here
and we're actually going to even have a
look at writing our own iterators for
our custom data structure
classes in the future but today we're
just going to discuss
how it actually works in practice and
how you can use it
basically a range based for loop works
because the vector class provides a
begin
and end function which returns an
iterator at a particular position so in
other words this is really just some
shorthand code for
the more extended version which we're
going to take a look at here
so if we were to write this out you'll
see that scd vector
with that template specialization of end
actually has
another type inside it called iterator
and there's a few different ones as you
can probably see here there's iterator
there's reverse iterator there's
constitutor
so just the regular iterator is what we
can use to iterate through the values in
a forward fashion and forward direction
from beginning to end
reverse iterator will do the opposite it
will actually start at the end and
go back to the beginning and then the
const versions of these are the same but
we can use it on a const vector because
it's not going to actually let us
affect the values it's not going to let
us mutate the values just simply read
them
so if we just select the normal iterator
that's what we have here
how can we use this to iterate through
all of the variables or all of the
elements inside this std vector
well you'd write a for loop just like
you did here so we'd have an iterator we
can call it i t that's a common name for
it for iterator
and we'll set this to the beginning of
our collection which is going to be
values.begin
then we need to check the end condition
so in other words just like with any
other
for loop at what condition does this for
loop break
at what condition does it terminate so
it terminates if this iterator
or rather at what condition does it not
terminate right so
this for loop will run as long as this
statement is going to be true
so as long as the iterator is not equal
to the end of
this collection so values.end will
return an iterator
that is actually already outside of the
accepted range it's basically an invalid
iterator so
this is not really the end it's not the
last element it's
the element after the last element if
that makes sense
and then finally we need to write
iterator plus plus you can also write it
as
plus plus iterator or as a postfix as
well iterator plus plus it doesn't
matter in this case now let me just
slightly clean up this code and drop it
down a bit so that you can see it all
okay so that's it we're going through
all of our values so now that we have an
iterator though how do we get the value
at that iterated position
well you have to de-reference the
iterator as if it was a pointer
this works because they've just
implemented this the reference operator
kind of asterisk function
inside the actual iterator class okay so
now to print this out to the console
we'll follow the same strategy as before
we simply dereference the iterator and
print it out like this
and now what we should see is our one
two three four five elements being
printed for the third time
and that is of course what we see over
here great so why would you
ever use iterators like this and to be
honest the answer is you probably
wouldn't these days because a range
based for loop is
essentially shorthand for this and of
course it looks a lot cleaner
however there are certain situations
where you might want to manipulate the
position of the iterator a good example
is if you want to erase an element but
still keep iterating over
the rest of the collection in that case
the iterator gets invalidated you have
to deal with that
or maybe you want to insert something
into the middle based on a certain
condition there's a few different
scenarios in which you just simply can't
use this because it just wouldn't work
you need to be able to manipulate the
position of the iterator and we'll
probably get into those
in a future video but obviously for
something like a vector or an array with
an index operator that simply takes in a
numerical index it just ascends like it
would for an array here
they're not really necessary you don't
actually have to write code like this
because
we can of course just write a normal for
loop and use i
as the index however iterators are
essentially
mandatory for other types that don't
have such a simple
indexing system because of course not
everything is just a contiguous array
with an index like we have here i mean
think of something like a tree data
structure
how do we traverse through a tree we
can't just increment an index
what about an unordered set i mean that
contains a bunch of
unordered elements if i wanted to print
all of them out to the console how would
i do that
the example i'm going to show you is
specifically the unordered map here so
an unordered map is essentially a hash
map it obviously doesn't store its
variables in any kind of
order and we need to actually know the
keys of the entries if we want to get
the values out of there
unless we iterate through them and
that's what we're going to do here so
let's create a little map here
i'm going to just write an unordered map
of scd string to maybe int we'll call
this map
so maybe this will like contain like
some kind of name like
cherno and maybe an associated score so
we'll write channel five and maybe
i don't know c plus 2 because obviously
i'm cooler than c plus plus
so with this map in mind if i wanted to
iterate through it
how would i do it well obviously i can't
use a for loop like this
because if i did that well my index
would just be
like 0 or 1 if i checked the map size
and that's not what i need i need to
actually
iterate using the correct keys here so
i'm forced to write some sort of
iterator so let's write this out as a
for loop that actually uses iterators so
what i'll do is i'll take the entire
type and you can see it's getting quite
long
and then maybe i don't want to like
modify these values i just want to
access them so i want to use a const
iterator
okay this is a huge type and because of
that it's pretty common to
use either a typedef or using along with
the type so in other words maybe i could
replace
this part of it if i wanted to and just
call it a score
map and then that would obviously
simplify things a lot so i can just
do this now maybe i even want to define
some kind of score map
const iterator or something like that i
could also do that by just
assigning this to score map const
iterator and now all i have to do
is write code like this i honestly end
up doing stuff like this a lot i don't
i don't ever really use using with
iterators like this
but i do use it with the type sometimes
so i'll leave it like that here
and then just implement this as score
map const iterator so iterating through
this map i'll set the iterator equal to
the beginning of the map of course like
i did before
i'll make sure that it iterates until we
reach the end of the map
and then i'll increment the iterator now
this is a little bit different
because this is a map i'm iterating
through a map so how does that work i
don't just have
one element right like i would with like
a set or a vector or an array or
something like that
i actually have two elements the key and
the value so how do i access them
well instead of just dereferencing it
you can actually use the arrow operator
and access two little elements here we
have first
and second first is going to be the key
so i can just go ahead and assign that
to key like that
and then the second one is going to be
my value and i'll just use
the ampersand here to get this as a
reference so that i'm not actually
copying the value so i have iterator
first and iterator
second let's go ahead and print that out
to the console we'll print the key
followed by an equal sign and then value
like
this let's go ahead and run this and in
fact what i might do
is just take away the other code that we
had here to keep our console nice and
clean
all right check this out so we have
churno equals five and c plus plus
equals two
cool we're able to iterate through all
of this now how can we
maybe improve this code to make it a
little bit better how can we
use the same kind of range based for
loops but with a map
well let's check that out so i'm going
to write for
auto kv that's going to stand for key
value in this case
and then map yeah it's that simple so
what this will do is actually
retrieve this pair this iterator first
and write a second
if you actually look at what it is it's
an scd pair so this is us now retrieving
that
std pair and now we can actually access
the elements from within that so i still
need this unfortunately
but this obviously cleans up the code
because i can just do
kv dot first and kv dot second like that
and then obviously if i print this out i
should get the same result let me just
add some end lines between this
and here maybe let's see what we get all
right as you can see we get the same
result obviously
but this again looks a lot cleaner now
can we do better than that well yes we
can as of cbs plus 17 we're able to use
structured bindings what that means is
that this code is going to look
even cleaner we can actually retrieve
this key in value
right here inside this statement we can
simply write
auto key value with this kind of square
brackets here and iterate through our
map
so if i drop this over here that's all
we end up with
and if i hit f5 there we go we're now
iterating through this map
three different ways and of course this
code looks
much much cleaner now keep in mind that
you will have to make sure that your
compiler supports people
17 and that you're actually compiling
with that if we go into properties here
as an
example you can see that my c plus
language standard under c c plus plus
and language in visual studio
is set to simple 17. if you're getting
compiler errors which is
quite common then make sure that you're
actually compiling with c plus
17. okay so in summary the only way that
we can iterate through a map or a set or
something that is essentially unordered
and doesn't have a simple
kind of incrementing index system is by
using
an iterator and today we've discussed
both using a normal iterator a const
iterator range based for loops which
actually use iterators
as well as structured bindings with maps
which is pretty cool and just
to be super clear the reason these range
based
for loop shortcuts work is because we
have an actual
begin function inside our map or inside
our well whatever collection
or data structure we're using that
actually returns an iterate in the first
place if we didn't have that
then that would in fact not work okay so
hopefully that was a good introduction
to iterators there is of course a lot
more topics that we can actually cover
in terms of iterators
i would like to for one write our own
iterators and we'll be adding them to
the data structures
that we've been going over the last few
episodes of this series as well
as i mentioned there's also some
advanced things that you can try to do
with iterators and i would encourage you
to try that out as an exercise as
homework
if you will so for example try and
remove an element from the
center of a vector and see if you can
adjust the iterator to deal with that
and likewise maybe
add an element into the middle of the
vector and see if your iterator can deal
with that those are great exercises
and i might be revealing those solutions
in the future but anyway i hope you guys
enjoyed this video
if you did as always please do not
forget to hit that like button and
subscribe if you are new
to this channel we've got plenty more
simple videos coming soon
next time i think we'll have a go at
actually writing our own iterators and
adding them to our
data structure classes but until then i
hope you guys have a great day
definitely don't forget to check out
skillshare using the link in the
description below
and i will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you